le prossime fermate che aveva la barba
ma scusate ma quale pochissime però
essere senza fare ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di dita
buttata questa volta ho pensato bene di
tornare un pochino io personalmente
indietro nel tempo e quindi poiché sai
farmi sapere non so aneddoti legati a
professori assurdi gite estraneo quegli
eventi in classe che diventano
memorabili ecco perché a questo punto
direi di stare zitto e lanciare subito
il tema della puntata che è la scuola
per questo tema ho deciso di ospitare
qui all'interno degli studios di questo
posto misterioso una persona che è
un'amica cara una professoressa ma
soprattutto la persona che riesce a
smorzare ogni entusiasmo e sto parlando
di sabrina la mia amica professoressa
benvenuta grazie quasi pronta
prontissima ciao ho una macchina non è
presente inglese la quale faceva di
tutto per andare spiega l'inglese entrò
con una fascetta scritti ma in generale
gestita come fosse uscita tre secondi
prima dagli anni 70 perché aveva deciso
che voleva mostrarci come ballava laing
il cotè la mamma aveva raffreddato ma il
professore che tipo io lo studente
vedevo come una persona non so che dirti
che avesse un pochino la la scienza
infusa la verità infusa c'era niente io
con questo mi rivolgo ai politici
bisognerebbe fare delle selezioni ma
davvero
io credo che apprendano delle persone
forse dei carceri
ho incontrato in passato delle persone
pericolose lezione di tedesco zew
tedesco con l'insegnante aveva ben due
apparecchi acustici e balbuziente debito
di vedersi cosa fare un di policoro
proprio questa scena dove iniziò a dire
i giudici da da una canzone di mietta di
kata in tedesco voti da un balbuziente
co2 sarebbe turisti g ma nelle scuole
questo potrei parlarti della mia
professoressa di storia del secondo anno
di liceo
lei sembrava non ascolta rimaniamo
quindi ho deciso di fare un esperimento
sociale e durante l'anno interrogazione
deciso di parlare di dragon ball si son
griffin fece anche una cena di latina
dell'interrogazione le disse bravo 9
questi qua dove vanno a fare
l'università trovano dei professori così
parlano di dirgli prendono 30 e poi
vanno a fare i medici si deve operare
questo di opera cui ville di s'è capito
tu ti trovi e che si è andato alla per
operarsi a crescere ti trovi con le
tette se non pagano interrogazioni
scienze al liceo s'infili svenire è
diciamo la fortuna di farlo del
professore appunto che era aveva fatto
un corso di primo soccorso e rianimato
io muove lingua un fazzoletto chiamò
l'ambulanza che io una tragedia se ne è
andata all'interrogazione
ho scoperto cioè io che ho fatto ha
fatto morire la mia nonna 15 20 morti
una volta volevo fare un party con dei
compagni che mi stavano antipatici e
servirgli dell'assa tivo e staccare la
l'acqua in modo da non poter scaricare e
creare quella che io del 7mo io da
definire operazioni
ma perché questa cosa e dell'idea e poi
[Risate]
[Musica]
la panna no io non glieli delle pesche
mangino questa cosa mi sconvolgere che
io so mica sua e se un giorno dovesse
venire in mente di invitarmi a una festa
coppa malù
credo una volta ragazza della mia classe
si nascose dall'armadietto per poi
uscire nel mezzo della lezione di
ritardo mani e bellissima sì che fa
dalla finestra
un'altra macchina frana allora queste
cose che abbiamo fatto e che quest'anno
fatto anch'io che con armi e bellissima
notte però passavo le ore nascosto
nell'armadietto il professore mi mise un
brutto modo alla nostra compagna e
allora abbiamo detto che abbiamo un
bello scherzo invece nascosto dentro un
armadio e noi abbiamo aperto le finestre
siamo visti tutta l'acqua in faccia
abbiamo fatto finta di piangere e ci
siamo messi a guardare 18 entra il
professore mischia porta cielo si inizi
a chiederci ma che è successo è successo
l'estate guardò e noi io la vedo
facciamo motorizzati dice addio a
cristiano stato risolto per il voto
degli ammesso io sarei morta ma stavo
scherzando questi sommati a volte quando
mi rivolgo ai ragazzi magari ad un po la
voce ma non dormo la notte
terza elementare un piccolo ma sente una
nuova parola a casa e non capisce bene
quello che significa quindi il giorno
dopo la maestra arriva in classe ed è
particolarmente truccava in truccata e
vestita a differenza degli altri giorni
allora il piccolo me pensando di fare un
complimento anni come un dio urla
maestra oggi è bellissima sembra quasi
una prostituta non scorderò mai
l'odio parolo che ha avuto per la mia
professoressa di reti toni delle
superiori una delle donne più omofobe
che io abbia mai incontrato a scuola
esiste l'uomo fobia
vedo che ci sono docenti che vivono come
non come un disagio ma come uno scandalo
questa diversità che diversità non è
semplicemente una caratteristica della
della persona questa professoressa molto
particolare tutti
e una volta che policy fatto la lezione
eravamo tutti in piedi un po distratti
libri articoli
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
ti ringrazio ancora sabrina è stato
invece grazie mille sapori ski forno un
compenso ne parliamo il mio legale
capire tutti offrono ceva va bene
ragazzine naturalmente ci vediamo nel
prossimo video e niente vi mando un
bacione grandissimo ciao quella della
cena non si taglia ed è sentito tutti
piegato la mano